one street musician had the audience  member of a lifetime while performing in  boston over the weekend uh yeah um rada  rao was performing a rendition of john  legend's all of me when john legend  stopped by to listen with his family  john and his family were visiting  boston's uh  phenyl uh hall marketplace and he did  not miss out on the opportunity to give  rada a huge hug and a tip after her  performance yeah according to the boston  globe rada didn't even recognize john at  first one with mass probably didn't see  him so it was just a coincidence that  she happened to be playing one of his  hits sharing the moment to instagram  rodda writes street performing at  faneuil hall has given me some of the  most spontaneous life experiences  grateful to have gotten the opportunity  to sing for the incredible john legend  and his family today take it away rada  [Music]  you give me  [Music]  and you give me  [Music]  thank you guys so much for listening  that's a surprise